t'aurais dans un bar il m'a fait une
vanne je m'en rappelle encore j'avais
c'était le début des téléphones
portables et j'avais un énorme téléphone
portable que j'avais récupéré je sais
pas où et j'avais mis à ma ceinture
il était 3 heures du mat dans ce bas et
il est passé à côté de moi et il me dit
excuse moi j'attends un coup de fil de
qui à 3h du mat et à esbarres en
rigolant et il m'a vraiment humiliée et
je me suis dit il faut que je refasse
une vanne et on s'est plus jamais
quittés
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est sûr que ça m'a changé ma vie
j'aurais jamais été là devant vous si
y'avait pas rencontrer cette personne
en fait on se voyait tous les week-ends
avec eric on se voyait toujours dans ce
bar je faisais exprès de d'aller dans ce
bar pour le voir on est devenus copains
et on riait
j'avais jamais autant ri de ma vie avec
quelqu'un je ne savais pas qu'on pouvait
rire autant je me souviens de notre
première rencontre je me ressource
on était sortis du bar et on faisait des
blagues et je me souviens d'être allongé
par terre avoir mal aux ventes et à cri
arrête et je connais pas plus que ça ce
mec là mais j'ai jamais vécu ça de ma
vie est encore aujourd'hui c'est encore
l'homme qui me fait le plus rire sur la
planète
j'avais la bande d'amis lui laver sa
bande d'amis et en fait on lâchait
chacun nos bandes d'amis pour traîner
que tous les deux et c'est nos amis qui
nous on lit dis donc quand vous êtes
tous les deux il se passe un truc est ce
que vous feriez pas vous devriez faire
des sketchs et spectacles et laïque eric
fois qu'on l'a pris au défi en feu vas-y
ldt cap toi tu ne t'es pas cap
j'ai dit tu sais écrire un sketch toi
fais non tête j'étais au théâtre non
plus j'avais jamais été au théâtre de ma
vie les guy bedos à l'époque comme star
muriel robin celles et ceux qui tenaient
le haut du pavé de ce métier et on est
et on s'est pris au jeu on est au burger
king en face on écrit un sketch vous
savez même pas quand il fait un sketch
on a ajouté l'officiel des spectacles
on a regardé café théâtre au bec fin
c'est le premier par ordre alphabétique
on a appelé quand ça se passe pour les
sketchs vous passer lundi vous appelez
comment ne fait pas eric et ramzy fait
vous passer lundi et on a fait notre
première audition et puis là le mec on a
repassé une deuxième et tout s'est
emballé on n'avait pas de
d'ambition plus que plus que ça c'était
vraiment rigolé tellement et puis à
l'époque y avait pas et il n'y avait pas
des réseaux sociaux il n'y avait pas
pour voir des gens marrant il fallait
aller dans un café-théâtre quoi tu
pouvais pas juste aller sur un stade est
tombé sur des métaux rôle comme il y en
a aujourd'hui des tonnes du coup c'était
vraiment un truc une organisation
fallait trouver de l'argent pour mettre
de l'essence dans la voiture on en était
là on arrivait de banlieue donc pour
aller faire des scènes ouvertes les
basij peu près de dix balles 20 balles
tu mets de l'essence n'y en aura pas
pour manger mais c'est pas grave on fait
le sketch et on se rendait pas compte de
tout cela c'était super mais quand on a
été payée en ai dit allez on peut on
entrer peut-être un peu plus en se
concentrant plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a c'est un
grand moment de ma vie parce que toute
ma vie a été consacrée à devenir
champion du monde de boxe et j'étais
vraiment concentré là-dessus et c'est à
mon premier combat que j'ai compris que
je ne serai jamais j'ai pris un ko au
premier round et je me souviendrai
toujours du regard du mec que j'avais en
face et j'avais compris que 15 secondes
où le gong retentit et puis on s'avance
pour boxer ces 10 secondes là dans le
regard du mec j'ai compris que je serai
jamais moi champion du monde et ça c'est
un truc qui m'a fait beaucoup de mal
pas physiquement c'est pas de cook a
fait mal c'est de savoir que c'est pas
pour moi je devais à 18 ans et je suis
parti à l'armée
[Musique]
j'étais à l'armée et comme je voulais
pas faire l'armée j'ai tout fait pour me
faire réformer et je suis réformez pas
p4p 4 c était fou et on te dis dégage
moi je suis p 5 j'ai quand même fait
trois mois d'armée mais mon dégagé et
m'ont dit mais tu peux pas aller et ont
été réformées mais tu te retourne pas
dans la société civile
tu vas à l'hôpital psychiatrique civile
et j'y suis resté trois mois et demi et
ça et je leur disais quand je me suis
réveillé sans le sang sans lacets à
l'hôpital psychiatrique où je disais non
mais attendez j'ai juste déconné moi
c'était pour pas faire l'armée et moi
j'ai eu c'est ça tu verras un psy dans
quinze jours puis pendant trois mois et
demi lui les psy pendant quinze jours et
là ça m'a changé la vie parce que ta
fille 4x est pas un bon souvenir
oui au début tu rentres pas ce que tu as
des connais un peu et après tu dis est
ce que je suis vraiment fou ou pas c'est
là que j'ai beaucoup lu ça ça m'a sauvé
la vie ouais à lire rien pu traîner avec
les fous dehors des ouvrait la porte
avec des oufs criaient les gens mais
sans tout ça je ne serais peut être pas
aujourd'hui